tre ragazzi uno di questi sono favi j
oggi siamo solo fatti nel caso non
l'aveste capito domenica siamo su happy
with cose che non ho mai fatto è una
roba che cazzo chino ciak continua
maneggiare extra roba ma anche
nell'altra vita faceva ma vaffan
omettere dante lo scarico sul telefono
già mi basta computer che gallows monte
nei ragazzi cominciamo perché ancora c'è
la settimana scorsa non l'ho fatto
perché c'era lo speciale dio o mega ois
scusate
sì ma stai calmo stai molto molto molto
calmo cioè non è che devi fare il figo
perché adesso c'è un bambino dietro e
devi farti vedere che sei un buon padre
ma [ __ ] spinning a vabbè con i
vetri che girano pure mancava pure
questa scusate se io mando liuc che gira
davo complimenti perché vedo che liu che
è capace a c'è se ne intende di vetri
fase iii by complesso sopra i vetri è
ormai nella forma non c'è invece sì sì
quando c'è un cazzo questo era
leggermente sottile ragazzi tutto è bene
quel che finisce bene tranquillo che
veramente io io non ce la posso fare i
livelli qui qui li vetri gli salterei a
prescindere veniamo con nonno ciak sul
cazzo appena successo ora gara l'ho
capita sta roba è stranissimo
ma cosa fa ma sentite fatemi vincere che
non ha ma cos'è cioè un arcobaleno che
che glitch a tutto il gioco ma non ho
capito perché va beh evidentemente sono
vivo sono viva
ora no ciak signore guarda che le gambe
hanno un suo perché comunque che
continuano a sculettare nonostante siano
staccate proprio dal nonno loro sculetta
[Musica]
impost è impossibile che non ci sta ha
scritto imposti con quindi abbiamo
abbreviato in imposto harpoon doge caso
è durato di meno di una mia
interrogazione di storia cioè venete
dello stivale e vabbè era impossibile
come facesse vivo pago del cazzo bravo
poco ed eviti devi staccarmi da milano
ma poi sono incastrato male è come se
fosse condannato a rimanere col culo per
aria speriamo che non passi una persona
malintenzionata tra l'altro è niente
l'ho perso non ci credo non ci credo mai
c'è felicità è melo pupin per traverso
abbiamo fatto ragazzi che la nostra non
fanno capito come ho fatto prima morire
ma vabbè vieni vieni tranquillamente
anto saving cazzo non era finito a
livello lasciato il pogo riso preparati
per la seconda ondata non mi ha preso
riuscita a sopravvivere così a random se
vinco senza il pogo bordate di lycra che
vuoi vedere il contatto da cazzola e
vuoi dare contatore di lei che esplode
se riesco a seri se vinco senza poco ci
sarebbe incredibile non ci credo o non
puoi morire così è
mi hanno lasciate lo stesso e mi piace
ma che avevo vinto è avevo ce l'hai
fatta
ecco la tua moneta cioè ragazzi avevo
vinto se non fossi morto un
rincoglionito sull'ampio ne avrei vinto
share alike lo stesso dai cazzo glp tv
el puffi aiuta puffi the pattern fisse
per pre apprendi questo biscotto devo
aprire cosa vai apri apri stronzo
dall'altra parte zio bravo ho vinto i
big more che cazzo me ne faccio a devo
andare sull'altro bottone by puffi the
butterfly ho trovato un biscotto mag e
chi è che cosa ti sei fumato
non ho parole sono vere sono disgustato
survive the bank sopravvivi al van che
van van rob van dam cosa stai facendo
non hanno un calendario succhia via
prima vedevo trascinato trascina veloce
nonno veloce dal di là non è ma quanto
sei [ __ ] ma come che si può essere
questi deficienti possa cambiare
personaggio grazie almeno lui rotola
prota la rotola verso la libertà
arrotola nor così solo tanta roba
fanta [ __ ] roba boltro poco fa cos'è
ma steve mandanda va beh ma anche tu
complimenti bella mira perfetto 22 no
thing c'erano e leo società beccalli
entrambi ragazzi ce la posso fare è
tranquillo cosa non è una cosa difficile
altro no sporca [ __ ] ladra alla
vittoria edizione se ci fosse una bella
[ __ ] dentro la vittoria a centrare
sti subito non trovo sto neanche a
chiedere vero frate nell'iva veli lo
vedi che la patata è la risposta c'è un
me lo dice pure lui non c'è verso ogni
volta che cazzo succede
sei morto e vabbè dai patata durata
dieci secondi ma è già qualcosa destra
your look dark mica che inglese che ciò
che fa la vittoria sarebbe rosa ma lo
centro subito zio dove solo dirmelo
[Musica]
michele obama con le sue medaglie
moderni e sempre in ritardo desert
icelandair run c'è devo correre su
un'isola deserta
ciao nonno è frate partono le denunce
quanto subito proprio quanto quando
quanto ti devo denunciare di melo
molestie sessuali su adulto è su minore
guardali che cazzo stai facendo
devo correre non so dove i jet z press
dow press ap che shark hewitt space nodo
salire sul sullo squalo fantastico la
fermi un attimo che bello press dow è
quindi devo mangiare cacciar con space
che ce la posso fare
vai vai veloce mi sto mangiando non lo è
più mi dà una tranquilla ho vinto c'è
proprio sono appeso a uno squalo
spiegatevi perché è il plain crescere di
uno schianto in aereo su è più istoriate
ho già fatto è infatti più o meno simile
però io mi salvo perché mi sono vivo
questo il mio culo perché comando solo
mio culo prima i bambini prima i bambini
prima non lasciarmi lo charme itu
[ __ ]
cavina è vale e chi è che mi ha staccato
una gamba non lo so però magari piglio
ecco userò questa qua che di un folletto
e la stessa cosa chi se no la via
gambara cima tieniti non con le scarpe
[ __ ] che si sta tenendo ti odio la
tua vita è una menzogna ti ammazzerò la
famiglia bastarda diamo all'altro così
adesso prendere il nostro figlio
scapperò via eccole compreso ho preso no
e la gamba del figlio la gamba e la
gamma allaga e vale certo prima o poi a
sopravvivere a sta roba
salve posso usarla come airbag mi scusi
lei io avrei bisogno di un airbag porca
[ __ ] c'è bisogno cosa sta facendo va
lì che porka's accadendo stanche
precipitare l'attenzione caminotto posso
sopravvivere storie gioco no minchiate
facciata
però son vivo cioè si fa per dire credo
che sia stato al livello più bello che
abbia mai fatto nella mia vita ho
ragazzi andiamo su golf che mi sembra
più tranquillo di quello di prima mi
stavo scherzando e allora tutti a chi è
bravo coprire una ma arriva e mi dicono
che arriva forse vari va indietro esatto
se mi arriva indietro provo a lanciarla
manco fossi tipo magic johnson con una
mano non ci credo ce l'ho fatta con una
mano sola
vabbè è tanta roba stream bmx park
minchia è così estremo che è morto già
gli occhi in partenza lo stai facendo il
bmx park bravo
c'è un ciccione che prova con lo skate
bravo bambina attenzione mi scusi
signora non volevo che finisse [ __ ]
la bici ragazzi non ho capito ancora il
perché è morta aveva mi son vendicato
per prima fantastico dell'abi gas lupi a
vuol dire che devo fare il giro della
morte vai così miyake giro dal cielo
anche fatta ma aveva vero ragazzi sono
vivo provino non so come non ci credo
non so come non mi fate domande non ho
capito neanche come ho fatto
sopravvivere va bene così
poteva non sarà un po più il volume che
non ho sentito bene ma vabbè the floor
isla va nel senso che il pavimento e
lava senso la va al pavimento credo sia
così
no proprio là va là va bene che che
bello fuori molto allegro
questo vuol dire che non devo toccare il
pavimento piano piano nella dentro
lavandino con la faccia come quando
tiravi la faccia la mattina stessa roba
che altro così si è fatta di ucciso una
lampada è una zampa di cidio al maglio
armadio madonna c'è chi faccia sul letto
proprio fantastica e fiducia sto facendo
su treviso
spiegami perchè il televideo e il divano
questo spesso ci fosse il televisore
sopra il divano e deve uscire la faccio
madonna come rovistò regate sono svenuto
per per la felicità perché in realtà ho
vinto dai ragazzi proviamo un paio di
via livelli prima di fa vj e i grassi fa
vj ai grassi non facciamoci domande
parigi poco games la rivolta la rivolta
dei ciccioni il mangiatore di bambini
c'è allora chi chi ha fatto questo
livello ragazze lei di ciccia mister big
mac fratello hai creato questo livello
con la connessione free wifi del
mcdonald lo so te lo chiedo è ciò questo
dubbio marcava e mista big mac babbo si
vabbè [ __ ] è impossibile non
riesco a fare due salti che muoia
sventurata ecco la trama vipera 97
chelsea in un posto bruciarlo scritte
verdi e blocchi cadenti vinci per
vincere
vinci per vincere non fa una piega
fratello ascensore a colera non proceda
ascensore si è rotto la sfida del
principiante a chi cazzo stai dando ai
principianti 0 attento tanto non mi
uccida invece mi uccide ma chi è che il
mana che lascia le punte affilate in
giro geniale questa supera le tv e
malvagie e quindi vai ce ne corre e
salta madonna letti uso proprio malvagia
e non è un quella non è una famiglia e
tv zio è un affare una tv normale con la
scritta fa vj che cazzo sto facendo
sto molleggiato tipo
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi con quello che l'episodio è
stato figo nel senso che mimì stupri mi
stuprate stuprato da un polpo stupite
sempre di più ogni volta quindi grazie
ragazzi per i vostri incredibili livelli
che migliorano le giornate di molto dai
ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto cosi video
piaciuto lasciato momento è un mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e camera i
video platea d'eccezione sono divertiti
iscritti che ci vendiamo vinto dai
ragazzi